[Music]
the world has a way of changing
but there's one thing that always stays
the same
you miss the old life deal
every day
crank it all the way up
i used to live my life a quarter mile at
a time
but things changed
my father now i will
always be in your heart
little brian i have a gift for you
your daddy gave me this no i'm gonna
give it to you
it's very special it's for protection
from what's coming
all right dom what's next
no matter how fast you are
i am not too big and fed to you no one
outruns their past
i am more easy
and mine just caught up to me
been a long time
so we're up against a master thief
assassin
high performance driver
[Music]
who is he
[Music]
jacob is dom's brother
your whole life you pushed yourself to
be faster than dawn
smarter than tom stronger than dawn
but could you kill him
because i'm ready if you are
[Music]
there's nothing more powerful than the
lover family but you turn that
into anger there's nothing more
dangerous
maybe this is the end but we won't go
out together you know i'd ride to the
death with you
let's get to work please tell me that's
not a pontiac fiero strapped to a rocket
engine
impressive i know no
no that's that's not impressive
my ass is
[Music]
i came here to take you down little
brother that's your mistake
this is my world
[Music]
damn they got a magnet plane hold on
tell me you're not thinking what i think
you're thinking there's no branch
oh hell no
hey guys
surprise nice clubhouse
[Music]
foreign